every day training managing our
economies in today's global economy
European countries depend on each other
more than ever before one country's
performance affects how the whole team
plans
that's why European governments have
agreed on a common training program to
nurture stability and growth throughout
the EU our annual European semester lets
us keep track of each country's
performance and tackle their individual
weak spots the EU works one-on-one with
its members providing independent
economic advice year after year and
helping governments to agree on common
strategies for stronger economies and
more jobs governments agree all together
on targeted economic fitness programs
for each country in the middle of each
year then every country starts working
out because Europe is strongest when
everyone's performing at their best
EU countries motivate each other to
stick to their policies and stay on the
right economic track sound public
finances are key to economic health so
they deserve special attention that's
why all EU countries have agreed to
limit the amount governments can borrow
each year and the total amount of debt
they can have borrowing costs money
so excessive debts cause governments to
end up paying more on interest and less
on useful things like investment
education research or infrastructure
parting the economy taking on more debt
than you can handle there's never a good
idea
it's also critical to look out for
harmful economic trends if a country's
exports plunged dramatically or house
prices spiked we need to examine these
trends make sure they are corrected
before they can cause serious problems
if problems are found we work
hand-in-hand with governments to correct
the issue until they have a clean bill
of health and are back to performing at
their best Europe is competing in a
global economy for us to win every
player needs to be on top form
the European economy stronger together